dream or not. Because his aunt T insists that he has a beautiful, beautiful, beautiful,
beautiful company which is everything in the state and everybody.
Ok, what else?
So, you, but he persists in his vision, you are insisting that you have to go to hell, you have to kill yourself,
there are a lot of things you pick up that narrative.
Step by step, you are dragging yourself and the people around you to that reality, because
there's no reality yet. But you are envisioning your funeral. You are envisioning your kid
and you are looking to your aunt, totally destroyed, you are dis-destroyed, you are acquainted,
totally destroyed. But that's your vision. That's what you see, you visualize, you look for.
No matter what is going there, you are learning.
Ok, what's next?
The next is, the next narrative is the opposite.
You see a guy who is, who is totally fake, insisting to everybody that is in today's room and everybody now is making a difference. Or not?
Ok, what's next? Is that it? Or do you have anything else to say?
No, no, it's different. On the other hand, there are, uh, I think that we are doing a problem.
Thank you, I look like it's both of you, you know, right?
Huh? You don't know.
Oh, sorry.
No, it's like one with, like that. I saw your little time grateful, could you see me and you're 18 minutes.
It's fine, it's fine. It's only 64, it's only 64.
No, I'm sorry.